the Fox News Alert my full monologue in
just a moment but first we have major
breaking news breaking right now as we
now come on the air tonight joining us
with this story Judicial Watch president
tom Fitton Tom this just breaking what
I've been able to read in just short
order is incredible what's what do you
have well more documents out of the
Obama State Department showing that
Christopher Steele Glenn Simpson had
special access to a person called
Jonathan Winer who was the Libya guy in
the carry State Department and Winer was
working with Victoria Nuland and a top
aide for Steny Hoyer the incoming
Majority Leader at the time well yeah
soon to be Majority Leader at the time
after the election all about Russia and
obviously targeting Trump it's just
incredible to see we could worry about
the Justice Department and Bruce or and
Peter struck well the State Department
it was all hands on deck in terms of
targeting President Trump they were
meeting with Glenn Simpson Christopher
Steele Clinton aides Sidney Blumenthal
another quote an associate Cody Shearer
there was more than one dossier
obviously going into the FBI and the
Justice Department not from only
Christopher steel but created by the
State Department itself targeting Trump
and the documents show that Jonathan
Winer was in contact with Glenn Simpson
in September of 2016
who then immediately contacted Winer did
Victoria Nuland a top aide at the State
Department and then after the election
they're working hand in glove with Steny
Hoyer 'he's guy on these russia issues
and obviously conveying information that
they were gaining from christopher
steele who was extremely close to
Jonathan Winer he was Jonathan Winer
where's Christopher Steele's contact at
the State Department going back a number
of years look let me ask you because I
got a couple of these you know when
Winer is writing to Ginsburg -
Christopher Steele mark Christie is a
friend of mine very high-end business
intelligence service based in London he
formerly worked for UK government
I spoke to Chris
it's complicated at another point in
another email about steel to steel and
his partner
requests for contact specific context on
behalf of the u.s. World Bank
International Monetary Fund Chris and
Chris advices you briefed the country
team it would be best that's not come in
from or through any US official but
straight on request in light of the
impact on Mongolia and need to know I
mean as you have now had more time with
these than me what do you interpret
these things to say the Steel's
relationship with the State Department
goes back a number of years he was well
positioned to launder the Russia dossier
information through this person Jonathan
Winer Winer admitted that he moved some
of the information over to the Justice
Department
so Steele has this relationship with the
State Department that's long standing at
least the Obama State Department then
comes election time he's contact becomes
his vehicle to launder the information
into the Justice Department and the FBI
and into working with directly through
Victoria Nuland that looks like another
top State Department official and Winer
who has really no business doing any of
this as the Libya coordinator at the
State Department on the Russia issues
with Steny Hoyer stop guy you know the
question I have here when you take a
step back is because we've seen other
documents where the State Department was
pushing Russia related material to
friendlies in Congress classified
information
just before presidents Trump's in an
order a ssin I want to know what
Democrats in Congress knew what and when
about the dossier it's pretty clear they
were in on it just as much as Comey
struck page and the Clinton and DNC let
me ask you one more question when you
when you say these documents show fusing
GPS and Clinton Walton paid for spy
Christopher Steele had a close
relationship with the Obama State
Department and the State Department
under John Kerry is emerging as another
center in all of this as it relates to
going against President Trump and Winer
writing an op-ed claiming that
Christopher Steele and
and confidante Sid Vicious Blumenthal
approached him with separate dossiers
what do you you know let's tie this
together if you can there was there was
more than one dossier you had to steal
dossier and it looks like you had a
dossier created by Jonathan Winer at the
State Department using as a source not
only steel but folks like Sidney
Blumenthal Clinton aide or pal and Cody
Shearer who goes back for a long time
with the Clinton group this is just
incredible in the sense that everyone's
been thinking that is suggest Department
the FBI that's where all the bad
activities was taking place Secretary
Pompeo needs to be working with Ag bar
as closely as any other agency head in
terms of decoding the deep state
conspiracy against then Canada Trump and
then President Trump and they were they
were desperate to get this information
out to their friendly Democrats on the
hill just before Trump was inaugurated
and it wasn't to help President Trump it
was try to destroy him and undermine him
all right tom Fitton Judicial Watch will
be digesting this now for the next
couple of days thank you for that report